scientists have long speculated that
sleep helps restore and repair the brain
now researchers studying mice have found
evidence that the cerebrospinal fluid
that washes through the brain flushes
out potentially harmful proteins when
the mice are sleeping the clean-out
happens twice as fast as when they are
awake for a hundred years scientists
have been trying to nail down where
cosmic rays come from
in 2013 the Fermi gamma-ray Space
Telescope finally spotted solid evidence
that the Rays which are actually
high-energy particles originate inside
the remnants of massive exploding stars
when viruses attack bacteria the
bacteria fight back and that defense has
inspired a remarkable gene editing
technique called CRISPR it allows
scientists to use a protein to perform
micro surgery on genes with astounding
precision CRISPR could help a naval Abu
and genetic engineering research
biologists call them organoids miniature
organs grown in the lab that used to be
science fiction but this year
researchers using stem cells grew mini
kidneys liver buds and even rudimentary
brains the size of an apple seed here's
a humbling thought most of the cells in
DNA and your body don't belong to you
they belong to bacteria that live inside
of you in 2013 researchers made
important progress toward figuring out
how these microbes and their DNA might
help physicians treat malnutrition and
cancer and other diseases perovskites
are materials that could make solar
power cells cheaper easier to make and
very good at converting sunlight into
electricity but they're not up there yet
with commercial silicon solar cells
still they're gaining fast a virus
called RSV sends millions of babies to
the hospital every year now researchers
have used structural biology to
re-engineer an RSV protein to trigger an
immune response
it's a pioneering accomplishment
big step toward creating a vaccine after
more than a decade of failure
researchers this year announced that
they had finally derived stem cells from
cloned human embryos the recipe for
making them included a dash of caffeine
the stem cells can develop into any type
of cell in the body and that could help
scientists study and treat disease now
here's a concept see through brains
scientists this year learned to make
brain tissue as clear as glass by
chemically removing fatty lipids that
scatter light researchers opened a
window onto hidden structures inside and
now for this year's breakthrough a whole
new way to treat cancer cancer
immunotherapy attacks tumors by
harnessing a person's immune system this
year saw promising results from clinical
trials researchers successfully treated
a number of different types of cancers
but this is very much a work in progress
it only helped a handful of patients and
there's still a lot to learn about how
this therapy works
you